hello
[Music]
i'm slightly early
from what i scheduled but hi
i believe we're live
one second
[Music]
are we live hello
good morning
or good evening
or good night
or good afternoon
hi
okay we are live okay lit
wait
what's up flasgow
gage farmer
ronan
hi pascal
what's up piggy
oh yeah i don't have any
it just cuts off i have been
playing through the game
with no sound
other than
voice
for like the past week
to help with uh videos
which has been
a grind to say the least
because i like having voice lines in
videos where they don't uh
you know there's no
sound in the background you just hear
their voice
so i had to play through the game again
with no sound
[Music]
to do that which has been pretty tough
it it the sound is very very nice
but
for videos
i want everything to be quiet
especially when i'm using like a voice
line from somebody you know
you know okay what should we do
hmm
i i never know how to choose because it
really doesn't matter
[Music]
my first playthrough i ever did i did
vagabond
and that wound out wound up being pretty
good
oh
[Music]
what's what is technically the best
class
is it confessor like to start with
[Music]
it's not it's really not gonna matter
hero does sound cool
i think or it's samurai
samurai might be the best
geez level seven okay
nine eight seven five oh my goodness
i mean annie get the uchi katana which
can actually carry you through the game
honestly
i might just go samurai
um
this this right here is actually very
flexible
you start with decent everything
let's just start samurai
all right what's his name
sekiro
sakiro
[Music]
pongo
craig
i'm gonna go with sakura
because all this doesn't matter um
yeah
might as well
all of this doesn't matter
giga chad
let's go
i don't know what kind of build we're
going for here we are just going to play
through the entire game bro that's my
plan
and obviously that'll take a very long
time but
at least we know where we're going kinda
the fallen
tell a story john elden ring
oh it's good to hear man i'm glad i can
be helpful i'm very uh sorry to hear
that
but hopefully all is well
have any of you ever beat the scion
not on new game plus
like just with a new game
queen i don't know how you could
what up kyle
and in the night of the black knights
man godwin the golden you guys are good
at the game was first to perish
i might go and straight get another uchi
katana
i know exactly where another katana is
and i can just duel katana it up the
entire game
i have yet to do an intelligence field
though of their newfound strength i
don't know why
triggered the shattering
we'll see we'll see we'll just play
a war
from which no no
is easy
easy
everything's been good kyle
the call of long-lost grace
speaks to us all was there ever shakiro
dlc
[Music]
chieftain of the badlands
[Music]
thank you nova i'm glad you like them
a lot of people make me think i'm
terrible at making videos
that's their opinion but
i appreciate that
the lowsome
dung eater one other
whom grace would again bless poopy
butthole dung eater
a tarnished of no renown
two years into production once secure
was released too busy for dlc yeah i
know they did some pretty hardcore
updates though
your quality is better than vati
no it's not oh
i'm glad you think that though
but it's not
ghosts
that's a big donor holy moly
south africa
thank you so much
wow
you are poggers dude does youtube even
know what poggers means
but thank you thank you so much dude
much love back to south africa thank you
for uh for being here
that is super nice of you
my
god chad who is this right here
was this supposed to be our maiden and
she's just dead
um
but thank you again ghost miss that is
very nice of you thank you thank you
that's your mama
that's your maiden how do we know that
though do we know that for sure
she doesn't look like my type
lol
yeah is it vikes maiden
youtube shuts down your stream if you
say poggers too much
oh no
that's not very pogers
read the message it just tells you to
like become elden lord right
though the path may be broken and
uncertain claim your place is eldenlord
she was supposed to help you when you
spawned but someone killed her
whoa
that's not cool
why would they do this
you got to get lightning powers
do i
i booted
okay
time to go die
you know what i'm not even gonna waste
my time look at this
i know i won't kill this thing
speed run
yeet
we'll come back later and kill it
i know myself guys i will not kill that
thing
hi booted how are you
i need to make you a mod hold on
mod booted now
boom
now he's a mod
long time mod there
don't fall for the arcane meme gc
have you noticed how the sights of grace
in the underground areas don't sparkle
like they do in the overworld
i have not
deathless let's go
who is your favorite in-game boss and
why
uh radon
fortune is on his side
because he's awesome
here after all
what build are we going for no clue
we're going with the flow
i am going to start with the katana
though
one of his kind is sure to seek
the elden ring
melana is a massive upgrade but she's
not technically ours even if it does
violate the golden order
who's your favorite boss chat mine's
radon who's yours
should we do the tutorial because i do
have to go kill
i do have to go kill that boss don't i
i just realized that
i haven't been down there since the
first time i played the game
legitimately
let it be known that eldon ring is the
greatest game ever made and i will die
on that hill i don't even think that's a
hill dawg i think that's just true
joseph
and thank you for the twenty dollars
it's 20 super chat
you guys are freaking awesome thank you
very much thank you very much
and that's not even a hill that's like
just true
that's just facts dog
thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
lord of blood
melania melania is growing on me a lot
malakath is freaking cool
horelu
morgot
all right you got it let's go let's go
find my favorite boss
he's right down here
moog's music is really cool
i i didn't like melania for the longest
time but now now i kind of do
i don't have my hood on
you won't beat him though
all right start a pole you guys think
i'm gonna die
yeah the godskins do have really cool
music i'd say it's the most memorable
music
how do i shoot this
thing oh i figured it out
here we go
oh
nerd
i hate melania she's fun but her water
flow dances is bs
it is but it's avoidable man
but i do think it's bs
i do remember when the game first came
out though everyone was really mad about
the godskin duo fight
it seemed impossible
but now it's
it's really not that bad
this area is like low-key really pretty
for a tutorial
you're about to fight radon right now
good luck
do you guys think radon is easy
i think he's kind of easy
he's like
i
bittersteel thanks for becoming a member
welcome to the great room fam
i forget what tier that is
dang that one was big
but thank you bittersteel
welcome welcome welcome to the agency my
guy
america
america
she's pretty lit all right
one in chat that i kill him two in chat
that i die
i want to see it
what do you think
this might be the easiest boss in all of
souls games
wow
oh my god
guys i'm stuck
i'm dead
let it be known i died to god's soldier
of godric
that that happened
man
welp
welp
you guys cursed me
ugh
you cursed me man
it's rick
it's pickle rick
like i died to that
wow
the parry god
guys i'm sorry
good thing we didn't bet on that
like man
that could have been bad
he let me
yeah he just left me when he's low-key
the hardest boss in the game
what do you think the lore behind that
guy is do you think there's really like
any deeper secret to him
this is so sad
listen
i was trolling i wasn't serious okay
soldier of god
it's pickle rick
i think you guys where i i asked a
question earlier and i forgot what i
asked
and then i did not read what you guys
said i'm a great streamer
i asked for don was easy and i'm pretty
sure most of you guys said post patch
he's easy
which i i agree
he's trying to become elden lord himself
and stop tarnish from trying to achieve
that first
act that's yeah that is a possibility
very much so
vary yes
tarnished are we yeah
between for the elden ring
of course you have
no shame in it
unfortunately for you
however
you are maidenless
without guidance
without the strength of runes and
without an invitation is redone a
gimmick fight i wouldn't call him a
gimmick you are fated
besides the um
to die in obscurity besides the summons
i suppose
so when he says you're faded seemingly
with blood all over him by the way
because you guys were saying that he
killed the maiden that was back in the
church of
the church that we start in
anticipation church something like that
i think
so he killed her
he's covered in blood
no wait what's that on his hip
little kunai okay okay luckily for you
i'm way too close to you bro there is
one shining brain yeah how would he know
we're maidenless
like if we had a maiden
would she just be walking next to us the
whole time listen
are you familiar with grace and he is a
mogu supporter that is true
yeah it's probably i don't know if we're
supposed to know for sure
is the guidance
but it kind of really show like points
that way tarnished must travel
indeed
grace's guidance holds the answers no we
gotta do the questline
i
i bet
i bet
do i even try to kill this guy right
here
ain't no shot
maybe actually with a
with a katana mmm
it's a maybe
i can't see
that's bad
dang it
oh my god
well that's embarrassing
i don't mess around with that attack
that attack makes no sense
no
it's gonna be close
i just didn't roll
no
no
if i had
one more blue flask we were good
that was so good though
i did not expect that for myself oh my
god
confessor has the best drip facts
that's true
uh since we all agree that this whole
game is america's scheme do you think
it's possible that america disguised as
the snow witch to influence ronnie's
life and lead her to turning against the
the greater will
like as rena
oh man that is a theory
i don't know about that
mate
that's that's the thing about this game
man
that that is the thing about the lore in
this game
i i feel like i know nothing
anybody else
when it comes to elden ring lore i i
don't i really don't know
i'm not a hundred percent certain about
quite literally anything
anything could be true
anything
we're all jon snow
i still think this entire like the lands
between is all not real
it's all a dream
waiting for the right moment
which is pretty much just that
when he goes away
nope nope nope
the lands between your mom
what
that made no sense
just saying
that was weird i was already fully out
of the the attack and it lingered
what the heck
all right one more try and then we'll
move on we got a lot to do
put these foolish ambitions to rest
i'll go kill margaret right now
i'm
upset
okay
tree get out of the way
well
this poll is really annoying
there we go
[Music]
oh
this is going well
yup that would have been uh sad
come on man
there we go
oh
yeah everything's easier it's a samurai
bro
everything
imagine if the tree actually just stood
up and walked away
that would be wicked
it wasn't first try but it it
that wasn't bad like that was pretty
good
yeah bro i've seen fan theories and lore
predictions that have uh
that have been better than the actual
release game movie or tv show
listen i i think they know
like from software knows it's like
let's just give
everybody in the community
a
just
a bunch of stuff that they can work off
of and explain none of it
you know what i mean
you're a tarnish so everyone can just
say whatever they think is true
and then have the weirdos be like no
there's only one thing that could
possibly be correct i am carly
purveyor of fine goods
i am carly
uh i would like
a crafting kit
thank you
goodbye
nice to do business what if this game
was a show
oof
you guys think eldon ring would be a
good tv show
i don't know about that
you mean a tv show that explains nothing
and just has a character running around
killing killing people
who say things
a good anime
potentially
a show with a death screen
why the hell does godwin have a fishtail
is it a fishtail
it is scaly
i'd watch an elena show boots really
likes melania don't you
we're getting a netflix show probably
not on netflix netflix is dying
i canceled my netflix subscription
you guys want to meet my wife
the two hour long no death all
remembrances run would make a great
movie
it really would
he added it as a finishing touch
i like that greetings
traveler
from beyond the fog
10 hours of melania's feet
oh
show us joy
is she down here
she is upstairs
i also do not have a camera right now
it's not plugged in
i
offer you an accord
i love hondas
it's the only joke i can make about that
have you heard of the finger maidens
finger my what
they serve the two fingers
two fingers offering guidance
and aid
so when you guys first played this game
and melania said this did you actually
think there would be a legitimate set of
fingers
or that they were just a clan called the
two fingers
because i thought i didn't think they
were literal about it
to aid you in your search for the elden
ring uh instagram
is agt jake yt be with you
joy is on there as well
yeah i thought it was a clan
then it settled
yeah summon me by grace
to turn runes and then i see like an
actual set of fingers i'm like hello oh
another matter
i bequeath to you this ring
the queath is a big word
use it
to traverse great distances
you guys ever said that world sure said
bequeath
named tauren in your life you ever said
that word torrent has chosen you
treat him with respect
i love torrent torrance honestly the
only character in this game that i
can trust
shall i turn your runes to strength
let my hand rest upon you
for but a moment
share them with me
your thoughts who's messaging me
cut it out the principles you would
follow
what should we level
you cut it out right now
why do i not have a
that thing on
streamer mode
can i do that for my phone
streamer mode
streamer mode
no no no no no no no
strengthened faith
is the um
is the golden halberd good
honestly vigor
not a bad way to start
considering our decks is already insane
is that squidward
no
let's see
it's insanely good
all right hold on melania
i gotta check this out real quick
because we did just beat
our boy
30 strength 12
okay that's doable
why's the last update make every build
crap
i might just do katanas guys
that's how we're gonna get through this
game like pretty easy because we're
trying to do everything
everything
i'm going to do vigor a little bit
index
well actually it's arcane right to get
that more bleed damage eventually
or is that only for uh like rivers of
blood or whatever
i'm just gonna do decks for now that's
always gonna be
this this is fine
shield only run
um we could go get the other katana
right now and just dual wield it
yeah it's only rivers of blood okay
that's what i thought
oh it is bleed in general
your mom sucks
i shouldn't have said that
a wall build
get moonville right away just to piss
people off
i don't want to piss people off though
zoro build moonville rivers and meteor
oh god
oh god
arcane is broke
yeah it's still really good
i guess we can go up to roderica
triple katana
we tried a dagger's build
wasn't the best
for certain
things dual
wave
poison katana
since no one uses it don't you get that
from volcano manor
you get that for doing one of the
assassinations for uh volcano manor i
think
you get it from tanf
that'd be sick they don't tell you
anything but you have to use context
clues to figure out what happened i
don't know if that would be possible in
a tv show though
not that i don't want to see an elden
ring tv show
i do everyone's i just don't know if
it'd be possible
everyone who came with me
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
only to have their arms taken should we
see if we can beat uh their legs
off the rip
no upgrades to the spider
did you know
if you're grafted by the spider
you become a chrysolid
it's quite a lark when you think about
it
i i agree farmer i i don't think it
would work in a tv show or a movie
and heading to stormville castle
enticed by the one in the white mask i
suppose
oh you've come to family
i hope they give us that in dlc in some
way
i really do
i want to be like everyone else but i'm
just too scared
i'm nothing but a craven
a craven oh i know
can you take this little one along with
you put these foolish ambitions to rest
deserves someone braver than myself
and the spirits look rather fondly upon
you
it'll be glad of your company i think
yeah what what do you get from tanith
you get like a magma spell and you get
the serpent uh like katana
i forget the actual name for it
it was a pleasure to see you
oh
can you pass on a message for me and
then you get access to ride cars
in stormville castle
tell them i love them
and that
despite my crash
i'm sure i'll be joining their club soon
enough
i'm finally getting the hang of this
whole pain thing you know
uh ronald is alive mike
rinald is alive
reichard's technically alive
radon's dead eleni is dead
uh morgot's dead margaret's dead because
they're the same person um
godric's dead
roderick and hugo are alive at the end
how long you stream for today jake no
idea i always just go with the flow when
it comes to streaming man i do want to
stream more
um obviously i'm very focused on making
videos
um but i would like to stream more on
youtube i enjoy it every single time
die
yeah mickel is alive
well we actually don't know that
is he alive
no idea
is he just asleep
is moog carrying around a corpse
is that even michela is that even
mickela do we know that
like that's that's that's the thing
about this game man we don't know
nothing dude
streaming yeah i'll be live for a
hundred hours
around around 100 hours today yeah
tarnished
in search of the elderly
emboldened by the flame of ambition
it looks like he cut off some horns by
his right his left eye doesn't it
sounds good empty
in the end do all the crone ladies die
in the past before the elven throne
i haven't checked that extinguisher
is he horny
where's roger
hello
there you are
oh god
oh wow
he has a sex dungeon what
he does
passing skill
warrior
okay this is where he gets kind of crazy
i still have to this day
no idea how to dodge that attack
calm down man
that's the opposite of calming down
okay this is gonna be close
you dodged in
i figured it out
first try
you dodge into that attack
smoldering with thy meager flame
cower in fear
of the night
the hands of the fell oman shall brook
thee
we're getting pretty good at this game
huh i mean
holy i have never seen her here what
i've been testing you
to see whether or not grace truly does
guide you
and
she is here early challenge that entails
it seems my worries were unfounded yeah
ronnie lies to us technically melano
lies to us whereas i merely pretended
margaret lies to us one other thing i
can do to offer you guidance
i can take you to the round table hole
place
of tarnished champions to our knowledge
rena is um ronnie's
teacher
very well
let my hand rest upon you do you guys
think renna is ranala because i don't i
think it's a totally different person
because they say that
rena is the snow witch and dresses like
ronnie does so it can't be ronaldo so i
don't know why some people say that rena
is ranala
just because their names are similar i i
don't agree with that one
[Music]
i can't believe we killed him
like that fast that was kind of nuts
not expecting that at all
let's go with that yeah it's totally
different totally different
the good question is how many sets of
two fingers were there
um
i don't know you
you guys know that the gideon video
should be put up
put back up today
because today marks the 10 days
with that whole situation if you know
about that
for the the gideon video to be put back
up
hi mark
just noticed on my latest playthrough in
lane dell when going to a fight at
morgot there's a bunch of dead finger
readers
um would love to know the story behind
that one you mean yeah leading up to the
bed queens
bedroom
i think
we need to go get uh okay i know what we
need to do
we need to go back here
we're gonna go get the second katana and
then we're gonna go get upgrades
is new game plus worth it i busted my
ass exploring everything
into white but all is kind of meh
um well you keep
your whole map
uh i i absolutely think new game plus is
like a totally different experience
so yeah
you should
i'm just gonna say yes
my thought was all those finger readers
died to the assassin that's waiting
there
but we don't know that
did you meet ronnie already no we could
go and do that
after i get my katana i'll do that
[Music]
i'm stuck
i'm stuck
i didn't expect to watch the stream from
you but i'm glad to be here thank you
john i'm glad you like it
i love streaming i just you know i've
been focused on videos recently
come over here
please
did i not hit him okay there we go
get some stony boys
uh-oh
did you restart the complete run
if you're talking about like all quest
lines yes
because that was like two weeks ago
and i want to just do like a hundred
percent
completionist run
with help from chat because honestly
it's really hard to know
if i've hit everything
so you guys will be like oh you missed
this area and then i just go there you
know i mean
i think it'd be good to
stream instead of just trying to figure
it out
because every everyone has a different
like experience playing this game
yeah we don't know about nicola and
melania's shadows we don't
i don't believe so
yes every boss and by the way if you
guys want to follow along i have this
which is in a spreadsheet
that shows us every
um
boss in the game
so that's in the description if you want
to follow along
we killed
we killed the guy at the beginning which
is soldier of godric so he's done
um we killed margaret
which is
uh we killed the tree sentinel
perfect
let's cavalry margaret the fell omen
dead i believe those are the only three
we've killed
aha there you are
so yes
you can follow along with this we're
going to try and do this entire thing
and this this will take us a long time
it'll take us many many many streams but
it could i think it'll be fun
it could be very fun
[Music]
let's go get that a second katana
whose pelvis
is mickala's egg resting on
i don't know
i don't
i don't know
and we'll kill this boss as well
go back over here
no it can't be rinalla
renal is the mother of reichard radon
and ronnie
okay there we go
why did i run back this way silly jake
this does not look good
oh chat i ordered a um
i ordered a standing desk
which i'm really excited about
[Music]
because i get whenever i'm editing like
for free all day i get so antsy and like
fidgety and i just want to stand
so i got a desk coming in where i can
just do that and not stop editing
okay
boom boom
there it is
i'll be dipping up some studying catch
on have a good one have you two
have a have a great day glory
black knife assassin
i don't know if i can get this assassin
with that
fast
oh you can catch it
you guys like grass yes
whoa
man it's moving right now
here she is
now that we know these assassins are all
women and newman
there we go
which is guaranteed like that's a that's
a fact
which is
every every time i can i can say that
something is a fact in this game is a
is a good moment because it's very rare
it says it in uh the what does it say
newman's rune
their armor set
feels good
why is the assassin there so my
assumption is that it's
so it's there with three quarters health
because it's hurt from
it's still hurt
from whoever
it try i wouldn't i i don't want to say
it's from the night of black knives
because the night of black knives was a
very long time ago
at this point in the game
so i don't think it's that
i'm not sure though
mykolo created the cocoon and embedded
himself in the hall tree to
try to go grow into an adult
moog the predator stole it guys what
what if we come to find out that moog is
like the good guy
wait like is there a possibility of that
probably not
if i made a video called mogu is the
good guy
it would get so much hate be like no
clearly not
that's so not true
people get very upset
moog the kidnapper
is michela technically a kid
what the heck was that did you hear that
my game went
that was weird
moog is the hero
yeah i don't know what's going on with
moog
i noticed the ghost in the weeping
peninsula uh when talked to says
the walking mausoleum prows praying
carrying the soulless
demigod america queen eternal
he is your unwanted child
carrying the soulless demigod
that would be godwin right that would
have to be godwin soulless demigod
he is your unwanted child
well that would kind of prove our theory
in our last video wouldn't it if that's
true holy [ __ ] that's a good find
i shouldn't even hurt these guys like i
can't hurt them without a blunt weapon
just gonna take their stuff and run
um not even going for that not worth it
i'll die over there
i mean if they're saying soulless that
would be god one
i don't think they ever refer to almonds
as soulless do they
church at pilgrimage weeping peninsula
i know where that is we can go check
that out
yeah yeah
godwin is
i mean we only see him as a giant husk
in the deeper depths
depths
yeah there's like several tears to the
south
to the southeast
stay
he won't
on this week to catch an imperium
yeah the death guy next to fear yeah
okay dude
why is he a fish i personally don't
think he's a fish
it looks like a fish
i think it's scales
dragons have scales
oh my god
goodbye
was i looking the wrong way i think i
was
i kind of want to look more into godric
yo what up trey how you doing today
i feel like there's more to godric
than
we're seeing
what up jordan
hello
hello what's this proximity to the
crucible
it's pretty close
pretty close
what's up fj
to hand a weapon to kill
oh yeah i could do that couldn't i well
no even with the katana that i have it
still would
dink right off him
i just run past them i don't even want
to kill him
we're gonna kill this guy real quick
though
jesus christ
doink
no
doesn't do one more big swing
what
okey-dokey
nice
what's the story behind the [ __ ]
crucible knights
well they're um
they are what came before the erd tree
the uh crucible what's what's the tree
the old tree called
is it just called the great tree
i forget
uh let's go to the round table
do some upgrades
eldon ring 2 will be the greater will
running out of options and making
patches in imperium oh my god
the great tree okay
got it
your new face
haley tree is another one
loud
that's nicholas tree
i like boots
i like boots oh i like boobs
chat press one if you like boobs
oops
thank you trey for the five dollars
that's a very kind of you thank you
boobs
okay now what we can go to
i mean you guys think we can kill godric
already
let's go
we need to talk to nafeli too
my kids just gave me this challenge had
to stop
had to start as a wretch with no meta
weapons
you mean doing like 100 playthrough
that's not that's not so bad
you'll find you'll find a weapon that
you like and you'll get through it
oh let's go to ronnie real quick as well
let's go over here and meet ronnie
this way tarnished may i have a word
this way tarnished
may i have a word i've been playing this
game way too
much pleasure to meet you tarnished you
too mommy wait what
i'd heard tell of a tarnished hurtling
about atop a spectral steed you hear
that line right there you know how hard
that was probably to say that
like what did she just say ah
as i had hoped
i was entrusted this for thee hurtling
forth spirits
summon them with it
from ash and return to the urgery i like
maxor's videos that editing is just too
much for me though as they recall
battles pass sub free now it is dying
to do it as thou wishest
all right how many of you guys married
ronnie
my first playthrough i did forgive mine
intrusion tarnished
i doubt we shall again meet
but all the same
learn well the lands between
how long will it be i wonder
before the tarnished tire of a basins to
the two fingers
man dude the the voice acting in this
game is like absolutely incredible it's
so
good
they see me hurtling they hatin they see
me hurtlin
they hatin
patrol
america trying to catch me riding dirty
catch me riding on torrent
catch me riding on torrent
come over here won't you
god i want to kill him
i'm gonna let you know what you're
you're tarnished i am i ain't messing
around with this guy this guy's stupid
open the main gate of course
this guy dies today right now
right now
hello
bones
what the f
hello
holy
oh my god
a 500 super chat are you serious dude
with no message at all
are you kidding me
my god
this is for you bones
bones thank you so much man
holy
[Music]
why is it always me
what did i do to deserve
that's a different dialogue from when
you kill him in uh godric's area that's
cool
bones can we get some like i what do you
what do you guys do on youtube
what do you what do we do on youtube to
hype up something like a 500
super chat
uh
i'm gonna put
oh you died
you died
that's one of our emotes too by the way
if you want to become a member
that's that's one of my emotes
bones thank you man that's
that is way too much
i appreciate it man how you doing i
haven't seen you in a while what up what
up what up
i don't know what meta is on youtube
rarely watch youtube lives i mean i
streamed on twitch for
four years and recently left twitch so
i've been having a lot more fun on
youtube i'm not gonna lie
a lot
so bones thank you man
appreciate the support
you are a legend
oh
that's not what i wanted
[Music]
you don't like getting spam with pepes
not exactly
you know i i actually should ask you
guys this question that i'm just
randomly thinking of
why do you guys watch youtube instead of
twitch
just anyone that's here
streaming like 18 hours every other day
so exhausting
wait really
oh [ __ ] i need to watch your streams
are you streaming on twitch bounce
twitch lags
um i like twitch better for the emotes
people are toxic video players way
better i agree with that video players
wait way better
it's just better
watching youtube for 10 years just
couldn't get into twitch
it's more convenient i can pause and
rewind that's big that's bigger than
people think like if if someone really
wants to go back in a stream you can't
really do that on on twitch very easily
like you can here
uh how
do you beat radon you just hit him more
than he hits you
which is another platform to get to i
have my go-to channels here so it's
easier to hop into a stream okay so it
seems like it's really like
just based on your preference okay
and then bone said he liked the the
emotes i i agree with that i think
there's like a better
not a better just a different chat
culture
on
on twitch it's it's they they get really
into the emotes where i've had actually
like
my youtube chat has been amazing
yeah everyone goes sub to bones
now
um
ow
that hurt
wow
this is gonna be weird
when is emote only mode uh whenever you
guys are being bad
you guys aren't bad
right
you guys are good
when's the moog lore video coming
i don't know
i did uh make a community post about the
next lore video
and i asked people what they wanted to
see
and
the least voted on one so far
was moguin
moguin's palace
welp
i uh did not mean to do that that's my
bad
that's my bad
no everyone goes sub to bones on twitch
where's my stuff okay
are you gonna kill the duo boss before
radon
is there a duo boss before we're done
you predicted it man you manifested that
and you killed me
you did that silent
see i thought that too well but it not
not
at least not what people voted on
jesus
the hardest enemies in the game
birds
my god
all right let's meet nafeli real quick
be proud
you were a fine warrior
your only mistake was your choice of
muster
dogs are easy compared to birds
to a higher place
i'd rather fight
dragon lord plastics than a bird
well who do we have here
tarnished are you
it's the camera yeah i am the philly lou
tarnished on warrior like you
i'm here by decree of my father
how utterly repellent this is
this grafting of godric's ill befits a
lord
he's tainted the very winds
if you intend to challenge godric
i ask you call upon me the winds run
foul with his deeds
i'm certain father would permit me aid
the fight
god i've heard all this dialogue so many
times
but i i do want to show you guys
dialogue if you haven't heard it before
get one of those
run past these goofs
i'm pretty sure we can kill godric i
find godric to be easier than margaret
now
the birds in fair missoula yeah those
hawks those why did i say like that
hawks
are so so hard
oh i don't have any of those um
yeah this is fine
it is fitting that he's easier
it really is
all right let's get it
summoned to philly because why not
yeah you can kind of just stand there
you guys will see
you get the buckler
i do like that shield that's got to be
the best one for perry's
heina feli let's get it
stan how we doing brother dragon
you try and get a smithy stone minor
bell early
oh yes we can go there shadow
that's my plan after this boss actually
yes deliver me unto
greater heights
well
neither did i irma
i did find elmer in the shaded castle
though
hello
i'm great stan good to see you bro
i command thee
i
am the lord of all that is golden
ending the runs and attempts at being
elden lord of many charged
well yeah that's his whole goal is to
stop us
no fella get out of the get out of the
shot
try and get that bleed
nope
might get it here there it is
one of the best music and best ost
musics and music in the game
truest of dragons
you only uploaded a members
um i think i accidentally did bones
because i didn't want to do that
so that's my fault i should do that
though i could upload videos a day early
for members
[Music]
god that line is sick dude bear witness
now
i can't see
myself
what the
yeah he's way easier than margaret we
did beat them first try both times so we
are getting good at this game finally
yay
i thought the voice acting in bloodborne
was good then i got an elden ring dude
bloodborne
for for what bloodborne is
bloodborne is an incredible
game like is top tier as eldon ring is
but they're they're like two completely
different experiences you know they they
really are
a little more endurance
that's fine
oh yeah i killed him is his head still
over here yep
i'm sure everyone has noticed this but
you can see godric's face stuck in the
mud right here after you kill him
and then you if i didn't kill gostok
he'd be slamming his head
uh okay let's go
you should stream bloodborne
i would love to do that if i could get
my hands on a ps5
if i can get my hands on a ps5 i would
love to stream bloodborne
but i do want to stick with elden ring i
don't want to
you know
i don't want to mess with the algorithm
the algorithm is is scary
but bloodborne is one of my favorite
games ever
even with
20 fps on a ps4
[Music]
one of the best moments in the game
right here guys
is it not 60 fps on a ps5
you know what i said first time i came
here and saw this
i believe the words that i said were
[ __ ] me
[ __ ] me
but but they do that every time by the
way for cinematic effect where it's
foggy and rainy and if you get close
here it clears up every single time by
the way
every time
oh we should get godric's rune shouldn't
we
let's go do that real quick
oh also there are people that say the
graphics in elden ring are bad can can
you believe that
there are people who think that
do you know if there's a reason to why
from software doesn't support ultra wide
i don't think they have an any game that
they've ever made so
i don't know the reasoning why they
don't but
they just don't
i think everything you see in the
distance you can actually go to it it is
kind of a lot yeah
it
i mean at least for me this is the best
game i've ever played easily
now
god damn my timing is insane except for
that one attack
i don't want to talk about that though
nice shot man
[Laughter]
that was a that was a close one dude
oh my god
any dlc coming not to our knowledge yet
but they uh
there is a hundred percent guarantee
that there will be many
many dlc's in this game
yup
just because everything doesn't look
ultra realistic doesn't mean the
graphics are bad
i i would i would compare eldon ring to
i mean let me know if you think this is
a good comparison i would compare it to
looking at a painting
i feel like when i'm looking out into
the world of elden ring i am constantly
looking at a painting
now paintings obviously don't look super
realistic all the time but they're still
beautiful
and they don't need to look ultra
amazing
it's clearly beautiful
yeah like those over-the-top uh i mean i
just think of transformers
as like
the over-the-top
ultra realistic cinematics would just a
story that i could give
no shits about
do you have any other channels on
youtube nope
i had another channel with like 20 000
subscribers
uh
that i decided to get rid of a long time
ago like two years ago now
i was a valorant
content creator if you guys didn't know
that
[Music]
and a rocket league content creator
mostly on twitch for a long time
i coached rocket league for like six
years
boom
i think godric's great rune is probably
the best in the game
any way to join your membership uh there
should be a link in the description
if you're on mobile
it's very weird but somehow doable
the link in the description should show
you
oh we should play demon souls if i get a
ps5
i've never played demon souls
well i borrowed someone's ps3 a long
time ago and played half of it
yeah just don't be on mobile
oh bone said this earlier about um he
likes gifting subs or memberships more
than he likes just donating money
um
gifted members are a thing
just not for everybody right now i did
apply for that though
just just so you know
i did apply for that
see can i sell my runes to this guy
you surprised you don't matter why
don't
uh sell yes
um
i'm just gonna sell this i don't need it
purchase i like lanterns
get all our upgrades going
uh should i just go to the cave that'll
just give us the bell bearing to just
buy as many smithing stones as we need
or should i uh
just go see what we can do with i think
we're gonna be fine if i just go back
and upgrade now
but yeah youtube's got to fix their uh
like mobile membership thing it is it is
weird
it's not very easy to understand how to
do
now
those eyes tell a story
hell yeah bro
you know it man well
now lay out your arms
i didn't know you could use golden runes
without selling them
well yeah you can just pop them in your
hand yeah
okay boom
boom
when i up oh i accidentally upgraded
that one twice that's fine
what do these scale with so it's
strength index
got it
so that goes up 1
1
77 76
boom
we're cruising chat this ain't bad
we are cruising
you like this is weird right
like that
is anyone else just kind of weirded out
that the the two fingers are actually
two fingers
like we said earlier i i did not think
that they were literal about
the finger thing
what's weird about
fingers to the greater will yeah it's
normal
totally normal
to welcome you
let their wisdom
wash over you
great elden ring
root of the golden order
anchor of all lands giver of grace
wellspring of all
joy
until it was shattered
the tragedy i think the coolest armor
set is blinds has taken its toll
across the realm
life lies in ruin fall into pieces
foul curses
and misery spread yeah did you guys hear
that elden ring outsold vanguard isn't
that crazy
in just three months too
so it says that the tarnished are guided
by grace yeah let's let's go do blind
your great rune is a handsome shard of
the elden ring his fingers talk a lot
another of its kind
to become my elden lord
and restore the golden order
let the words of the fingers guide you
malaquez is cool as well
radons is cool but it it radons is like
so overused by everybody that it's like
not as cool anymore
but it is really cool
okay thank you ma'am
let's uh let's go check out blight
lloyd
all the religious books of the world
were written by
we're all written by someone's fingers
you you are right that is true
they look like your head shrunk when you
put on a helmet
they just squeeze your head
let's kill this dragon real quick we
could do patches
and uh yura
forgot that hurts you there
ow
thank you for killing that thing
no
tore it run what are you doing
what the heck he just didn't go anywhere
that was weird
no
fire does hurt
surprise he is not staggered yet
what
i think fire still hurts even when it's
cold
are you kidding
oh whoops
there we go
easy peasy is is euras still over here
even after we kill the dragon
yeah that that entrance to that dragon
is super cool he is here
is he still gonna warn us about the
dragon
you must be the new tarnished
beautiful work
failing that dragon
and as such
curious what he looked like
to know
the heart you brought
back it's used in drug and communion ah
okay you should find yourself overcome
by hunger for the heart
yearning for its strength then seek the
decrepit church
on the little island off the western
coast
okay you must not forget though
those who partake in drug and communion
will one day shed their humanity their
hunger for dragon
their yearning
only worsens until the floodgates burst
unleashing eternal torment
the strength of a mighty dragon
magnificent
but deadly it's no surprise that drug in
communion
is ruinous
what does ruinous mean i've never heard
that word in my life
thank you sir
see
i think technically what we want to do
is go south now
and then come back
to miss wood
yeah he said ruinous
i don't think i've ever heard that word
before
can you kill him now for his weapon
nah
we like him
to invoke ruin
leading to ruin
so it just leads to destruction okay
thank you thank you
yeah bring downfall got it
thank you
got one level
pop that back up to 15.
we're cruising pretty good here
uh we could kill this bear
right here
if you guys have not noticed that this
guy turns into a bear this is gonna be
weird
yeah he turns into a bear
how
okay
stay down there for a minute i gotta
heal
sir can you help me sir there's a bear
okay i got it
oh my god
sir
it gives you a larval tear
which is pretty epic
it's an erd bear
four godskin rune bears that'd be the
hardest hardest boss in the game
you get the naga kibby his weapon and
altus plateau i think it's the coolest
katana
uh the range is insane
gotcha
we'll see i'm just cruising with these
two katanas right now we're good
so yeah go kill that bear if you wanna
you know
get a larval tear
irina
hello
is somebody there we can start irina and
hayeta's thing please
my name is an edgar i've escaped from
castle mourn to the south
the servants there have rebelled
i
i can't be sure giant hand in the sewers
ended up finishing the dung eater fight
for me last night nice irma where i
heard frightful howling from all over
my good father secreted me out the
castle but decided himself to stay yeah
katanas are the best
as commander
godwin's presence in deeper depths is
similar to that not to mention the hair
the only problem with this is this
timeline and could have something to do
with america's plan
yes i think a lot of what goes on in the
game has to do with time changing when
we don't realize it
which i i don't have a ton of evidence
for this theory besides like time
clearly being a factor in pharah
missoula i want to do a lot more
research in in fair missoula and kind of
see what's going on there i
i fear for father's life
the servants are full wrath
filled with hatred for every one of us
they've since come for every one of the
companions really irma
i did not know that
that's cool it's no different at castle
please she seems nice i hope nothing bad
happens to her
at the castle
my soul wishes it no she'll she's fine
even if his honor should be the price
please
i just want him to be safe
thank you
dearly
then please she'll be fine take this
thank you deliver it to my father who
remains in the castle if you please
okay please
if you wouldn't mind
he can be stubborn okay i think that's
all of it let's go
let's go
we can also go like toward the right
over here and get like uh
sacred tears
we should probably do that first
yeah we should
that's golden rune this should be
smithing stones that we need
that's mighty shot that we don't need
um let's go here and kill the knights
cavalry real quick
that i don't think
is an actual boss but just an enemy you
find
thank you all for all the subs guys i
appreciate it
did we reach 40k yet because we're
really close
really really close
as time till nightfall
the question of whether or not america
was complicit in ronnie's murder of
godwins seems central to the whole plan
i agree
i agree
it's hard to know for sure
of anything in this game
we can make theories though
does eg die does anyone want to tell him
what's up slam
dang it
uh
nice
yeah i would say
gosh who who is my favorite character in
this game
i i i think it's blind
i think it's blight
my favorite boss is radon
but my favorite character lied for sure
see there there you go zendo
there you go he goes upstate
he he starts a farm
uh
with all of your all the pets you've met
and uh lives free and frolicks in the
flowers
he doesn't
burn alive
nope
none of that
the yep
blind going crazy chat is not his fault
not his fault at all
not at all
alexander's your favorite character
alexander is really cool
yeah yeah yeah he's teleporting
i
i remember my first playthrough and i
fought i fought against blide i i like
tried to figure out a way to not kill
him
and
there isn't
you know eg puts him in an ebergill
i wonder if we never let him out does he
still live in the evergale
was it this one
that the someone was talking about
earlier
yep mausoleum prowls clear cradling the
soulless demigod
america queen eternal he is your
unwanted child
he must be talking about godwin
bro we need to go check out those
mausoleums and look around because
could we see god went in there
or at least a figure of them
that was you okay i remembered
let's go get the other one
there's two mausoleums
i think
no there's only one
blood goes mad because he's ronnie's
shadow and she portrays golden order yep
it's not his fault though
even eg says that his own thoughts don't
matter
he's still gonna go crazy
isn't there a boss no there's no boss
there
who is the body inside the mausoleums
well
it could be it could be godwin now that
we're seeing that
let's kill this chick real quick
here let me go get my other secrets here
real quick
yeah most npcs you meet are gonna die i
knew that just because i played every
from software game beforehand
they all die guys they they never stick
around for very long
well i guess not all of them
last
don't have those
boom
boom i think that's all we got
yep you can save bach
do we want to save patches oh another
one
oh there it is the tower finally i can
return to our home
bathed in rays of gold
excuse me
there it is the tower
finally i can return to our home bathe
and raise of gold that's what godric
says
are you freaking kidding me
what
okay stay
i am curious of this person
what are these
i don't have a telescope
is that godric's crown
he's got little mushrooms all over him
where have i seen those i've seen
mushrooms like that before i swear
hold on we need to look around in this
mausoleum
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
a low game
oh my god that scared me
are these not like the skulls that um
i forget the guy's name
the guy that uh fights against us and
fee is boss fight
in the deeper deaths
the the
the guy with the fat armor
i find this easier without a horse
or i'm being stubborn
there we go
lionel
lionel
i didn't get all of these
thank you thank you thank you
there we go
i believe these guys go away
they die okay
let's see if we can find anything on
godwin in here
because that's what those little spirit
dudes were referring to
definitely
okay it's a corpse with a missing head
chandelier
kind of normal statues
yeah what's he holding up
it's like he's uh holding his hands out
to
hold something
[Music]
if i remember right some mausoleums do
not have a corpse in it
right
[Music]
newman runes on the walls
you mean these
hmm
i mean up there
this is interesting like could this be
godwin
remembrance duplication
okay
so now i have that again
[Music]
kind of looks like a kraken this
kinda
i see what you mean
let me get a better look
yeah godwin
did turn into the octopus thing the the
other thing about that is we don't
really know how that
um
how that transformation occurred
because technically
godwin's head
is the only one that we see
could this be godwin's body
i don't think we can know for sure that
is really cool though what is this
yeah i know how mausoleums work we're
just um
checking out something from
one of the the spirits say that
this could be godwin
he is burned
he's kind of burned like ronnie is
right
yeah that's godwin's head guys it
doesn't mean that it's godwin's entire
body that's in the deeper depths
it is very low profile though
might be a stretch
what about in this coffin
can i like
finagle it to see inside the coffin
kinda
doesn't look like anything's in it
the bed goes invisible check his back
oh yeah for the curse mark
hold on
[ __ ]
how is it raining in here
i'm trying this is hard
what if i
can we can you see his back here
kinda
i think we need to see it from this way
this is really hard
if we can see a curse mark on this guy's
back
that's a good view
that's perfect
i do not see a curse mark it looks
normal
godwin would have the curse mark
you guys see anything
i'm trying to look more at his like
upper right back
beep hello how are you
i don't see it i i think we're i think
we're stretching it here
interesting we need to look at more
mausoleums
really good
yeah it's not god one what is this
i don't have a telescope why are these
here
randomly
okay
where was that guy he was over here
right
are we looking at some crusty ass booty
no we were seeing if that was godwin
what was that sound
why is there a random jellyfish over
here
oh there's two okay look i mean
the reason we looked at that is look at
this guy's dialogue
the mausoleum prows cradling the
soulless demigod which would mean godwin
oh america queen eternal he is your
unwanted child
cradling the soulless demigod so
also that makes sense when there's those
little death skulls
related to fia in lionel lionel i i
don't know how to say his name
correctly
that stop us from entering it
holy [ __ ]
that's definitely a lead to something
we need to check more mausoleums though
that that is very interesting
does that prove
yeah i mean if if she really
if godwin really was his unwanted child
i don't know why that would be the case
though
i mean he
yeah i don't know
it's so hard to know
i'm so curious
oh my god i'm dead
wow that annihilated me
no i'm not saying that they're all
godwin
i'm saying that
apparently godwin has something to do
with the mausoleum so now i want to look
more at the mausoleums you know
maybe they put those mausoleums there
because they couldn't give godwin a
proper funeral
because they didn't have a body that's
that's true as well that's a good point
pascal that's a very good point
i'm i'm very curious now
now
holy [ __ ] i suck
i'm just thinking about this godwin
thing right now man oh my god
this is not a hard fight like at all
oh you guys like the thumbnail
if you're curious of the artist go um go
check out it's in the description
the person who made this uh the art in
the back of background of the thumbnail
makes is like works for riot games
wow i smell
i'm dead again
wow
radon doesn't skip leg day man
radon goes to the gym at 5 00 a.m every
day there's there's no doubt about that
even while insane he's still getting the
gains in still eating his protein chat
well the roll forward thing uh i don't
think i signed right
does this guy break these wait hold on
does he break these
yep
well now i want him to break everything
well now i want him to break every pot
what if there's something in one of the
pots
i'll crit hit him this time
i definitely get more damage not doing
that
there we go
what do we get for this
ah
for wonders physique
physique
all right
let's go
back this way
alexander 8 godwin confirmed
it's confirmed guys confirm
it's true
i like this guy
he gets right to the point
right to it
read lethal the headless ash's
description i do not have that right now
but we could in the future my friend
strength i guess
let's go to
the miss we gotten
let's get it
and then do uh edgar
as well
we're not doing blind next i want to do
this first
and then we'll go back to blind
oh someone copied it in the chat i i
didn't read it
i do not uh i could i can update it
after the misbegotten
the the boss list
which is in the description by the way
chad if you want to follow along as well
oh come on
yep
oh it's located in the catacomb next to
the mausoleum
ah
oh okay yeah yeah
what does it say i don't want to go back
it's pretty obvious there should be dlc
about godwin and mikala which knowing
miyazaki means that there won't be
screwed
very true
makes me sad
radon would sound like andre the giant
imagine
imagine we like go back in time in a
future dlc
which i really hope this happens and we
see everything before the shattering
started and everyone's just normal and
we talked to radon
and he sounds like this
hi tarnished
how are you
what are you doing here this is my
castle do you like it
i do hope we go back in time i i man
that would be so cool
so let me just go this way
hey guys how's it going
my name's radon
i hold back the stars for my horse
my horse's name is leonard you like him
i also named my dog kevin
i mean
do we know what he sounded like nope he
could sound like that
he's just a chipmunk
sounds like alvin from the chipmunks
uh hey guys it's morty here uh
i don't know about this rick
i don't
know uh
well
i guess so
ah hi edgar oh god
there's a face i've not seen before oh
yeah
you can see how things have turned out
the menials have all rebelled
they gave me good service
he yells at the sky
and he sounds like a beast
and true enough they're foul inside is
my morty good i'm sorry to disappoint
you
but whatever you come here to do
i'm afraid castlemore
[Music]
oh sorry sir if you see arena do tell
her
her father will come for her
once he's fulfilled his duty i can do
squidward too
scratch bob
it's not how you make a crap do you tell
her it's not very good her father will
come for her
once he's fulfilled his
nope that's not it
spongebob
moving on
oh god
i can do trump yes
indeed
it's all well and good yes
are you
yes
indeed
i am very smart very very kind
very presidential
maybe you can branch off into spongebob
theories
oh god
i don't know what i'm gonna do besides
elden ring
i don't want to do anything besides
alden ring
i don't know i oh well
eldon rings lifespan is gonna be very
long so i'm not too worried about it
i would like to play the other souls
games
on stream sometime would you guys like
that
like we played like dark souls 3 or dark
souls 1
bloodborne
i do want to get a ps5 and play demon
souls i really want to do that
i need to like really try and get a ps5
dead rat
yeah there's gonna be material for this
game for a very long time
play them all
dark souls 2
i've only beaten dark souls 2 one time
which means that's the only time i
played it
rp walk
holy [ __ ] he did a lot of damage
nice the delayed
i can't believe i died to this thing
stream marathon entire series in one
sitting
[Music]
you just gave me an idea
what if we did like a member-thon
where i start with demon souls
and play the entire series until our
member timer runs out and if you guys
really want to keep it going
we do the member thon
it can add like a minute to the timer or
five minutes every time somebody becomes
a member or something that could be
really interesting
but if it runs out i end stream
kingsfield
oh god
how old is that game
this guy's going off right now
dude
leave me alone oh my god i died twice
is it bad i want to brush radon's hair
are you do you know are you doing that
because you like them
we know at least two jellyfish are dead
kids oh my god you're right
you're actually right
he's hot not gonna lie
who's the most attractive boss in the
game chat
most attractive character
dude i
i don't know how to dodge that properly
my god
what is happening
did they upgrade this guy
or am i just that bad
i killed market
and godric in one try and i'm dying
three times to the misbegotten
ronnie is not a boss
okay most attractive character
you know she's a doll right
right card yeah yeah god skin noble
yum
i can see people fangirling over blind
for
sure a certain furry community maybe
finally he's net
you like the tree spirit
like the most forgettable boss in the
game is the tree spirit because there's
like eight of them
i would give blind belly rubs
me too
i also would do that
okay so we did that what's up let's
update our uh our list
unsheath is one of the best ashes of war
in the game uh okay so we beats
we're gonna do these soon
wait
is there only one er tree avatar
yes so we beat that one
we beat
flying dragon
we beat godric
we just beat lionel miss begotten
mad pumpkin head no
we beat the roon bear or no he didn't
that's a different boss
i think that's it for now
uh
uh uh
black blade
no we didn't beat bass beast man
yes shadow
we're trying for it we want to at least
in one playthrough have all of the
options at the end
and then we can have chat choose which
one we go for or something right
oh we did get trone uh yeah stone digger
troll
yep is that one is that one called scaly
misbegotten chat or is it called
this one leonid misbegotten
i didn't even pay
attention
i think it's scaly
no the the knights cavalry we fought was
not the right one
no it's not scaly it's leona you're
right
thank you thank you thank you
no no no
all right we'll get back to it
[Music]
oh tanith does have a good voice
we did not get the knight birdies yet no
no
let's go back here
scaling misforgotten is in a tunnel
skills to do the axe
i don't know if i've ever seen that one
oh no irina died oh no
brina
how could this be
my daughter deserve better
the [ __ ] lies
with me
i chose duty over my daughter's safety
and
that is how fate has answered
mourn tunnel where is that i'll find
them the foul wretch is responsible for
this the revenger down and exterminate
every last one of them
rest assured
arena
it will be done
smash your pass on edgar i can't answer
that question because oh [ __ ]
i'm rest assured
i fly straight
um let's go back over here i think
there's a ball yeah we need to do this
boss right here
actually uh we can also go to the uh
dungeon that's near here as well
why not it's not my type
not my type
no other reason
where am i going where am i right now
i'm lost
really hope you save her well you're
gonna be surprised
oui
ow that hurt
[Music]
yep
we're almost done with the game right
guys
almost done with the game
radagon scar seal
do you guys think hiata and irena are
the same person
they have to be right
they they've got to be the same person
i am very picky that is true there she
is
let me go get her uh
her grape
which is an eyeball
by the way
did i already grab it i think i already
grabbed it what does this guy say
maiden dear maiden where are you
please take my grapes
man this guy's really into grapes huh
just like your mom and your dad
if euro didn't come back to life later
that it wouldn't be as positive that
hayeta is irena
hmm
you're right right
hello
is someone there they say the same thing
hello is someone there
well she sounds a little different bold
is to ask
would you donate any shiburi grapes in
your possession to me
my eyesight has been weak since birth
you see
i can't tell which way i'm supposed to
go next
but when i do probably cause you're
blind
i can feel a distant light in the back
of my eyes
it will lead me to my true duty
is a finger maiden
many thanks to you
now i can feel the distant light once
more
you are most kind indeed
may the blessing of the fingers be upon
you
as you wish
okay
let's go
same voice actress but she sounds a
little different
okay okay okay
let's go
to
the cave over here actually
or do do we go in this cave yeah we
should we should should
it's fine
let me get my bearings
of where the f
[ __ ] i am
i hate
goats me
can have a little eyeball as a treat
yeah eyeballs are just grapes in this
game guys
they shrivel up and become raisin
eyeballs
hey i gave her someone else's grape and
she ate that just fine
you do some incantations or sorceries i
don't know yet
we're just kind of going with the flow
we're just kind of rocking and rolling
you know what i'm saying
oh we do not give it to torrent do we oh
no
oh god
i hate when like the the text is on the
screen and you can't attack
until you press y that is even prompted
get one of those in some of these
i haven't been in this cave in a while
yeah i don't think that stone sword key
was worth
like at all dawg
i ain't gonna cap on a stack
squish squilla
ain't gonna cap on a stack bro
[Music]
ow that hurt sir
don't ever do that again
i need to go watch the uh
i need to watch the
golf tournament
do any of you guys like golf in here
anyone a golfer
oh my god
try fingers
butts hole
i hear you oh you're over there yes a
terrible one
terrible
well what's terrible mean
you're probably better than you think
and
not really
don't keep score that's a good idea
either reason corey hasn't uploaded in a
few weeks
who's corey
shoot
no no death counter
i asked if anyone was a golfer because
if you guys did not know this about me
i used to play professional golf
i don't think i've ever said that on my
youtube channel
oh god
what am i doing okay
what
yeah
i played
golf in college well i played junior
golf high school golf college golf pro
golf
just on many tours i didn't make it to
like the pga tour or anything
and then i accidentally hit the back of
a tree root
on a downswing and
uh now i have nerve damage on my right
wrist so i cannot play i can't play golf
enough
to uh
to practice enough to be play
professionally anymore
i think we gotta go back this way
i got to play pebble beach in 2013 and
that's my favorite course ever
now we golfing is totally different from
normal golf
obviously
i made second round qualifying for corn
fairy tour but
uh never made it to the actual corn
fairy tour no
i played on the florida golf tour
the
a tour in arizona um
and
one in texas for a little bit
i didn't do it for very long i got hurt
pretty quick
in the villages not that i know of
this one's scary
what are these things
jesus
oh
how do i even hit it
okay
that was weird
okay so someone wanted me to read this
i forgot i got that again
legendary action remains used to summon
the spirit of luthor the headless spirit
of the headless knight who leads the
mausoleum soldiers
wields a lance enrobed in death and
hurls spectral lances at foes
luthor sacrificed her life
so that in death she could continue to
protect a soulless demigod
until their revival
earning her the hero's honor of urgery
burial
ooh so they're trying to legitimately
revive godwin
cool
that's actually dope
try pressing r1 thank you for the tip
no i'm not the completionist guy
sorry
that's interesting okay that's a good
read
oh my god this actually bleeds
nasty
okay
he will be revived
you you guys know godwin's gonna be a a
boss in the future come on now
you know what would be really cool what
if there was like a secret boss that no
one's found yet
to fight like godwin like a secret
you know
you have to do some secret combination
of things
his body is still alive
yes
but i don't know what we call alive when
there's nothing inside of that body
nothing
all right let's go to blight
yes
um or we could go to d
we could go to d finish d
yeah yeah d we can wrap around and miss
wood
that's what we should do
imagine walking to fiat and suddenly the
octopus face thing starts moving and
comes at you that would scare me scare
me
very much so
i know this is a very deep question oh
god alexander can you hear me
all right deep question time if you guys
found that like you had some accident
and you couldn't move your arms or your
legs or your body and you couldn't do
anything on your own would you want to
stay alive or would you just want to
move on hello i'm right here oh my gosh
i'm so happy this is a very deep
question i am alexander personally i
would not want to
and as you can yeah i would i would pull
the plug for me
please
can you help me out of this
sure my thanks a thousand thanks
just give me a good smack from the rear
with something nice and big
and i'll pop clean out i'm sure
don't dally that's a great plan
alexander
i'm very well trained
give it your all i say
locked in syndrome
no just like uh you've received so much
brain damage that you really can't do
anything on your own
but you're still technically alive
triumphant delight
ah
well played good sir well played
though that
mighty wallop of yours almost spelled
the end of me
well
i'm out now and that's what counts
yeah i've never really thought of like
maybe you like and i don't know the
token of my appreciation
i'd like you to have this sounds like me
on a monday
oh god
once again
the pleasure is mine
i am the warrior jar known as alexander
iron yeah so like god win irl yes i
journey to the east
the law says you can't die in most
countries
i i have heard that yeah beyond these
lands lie the scarlet rot blighted caled
wilds
and upon their southern edge is red main
castle
in which a festival of combat is being
held
i'd heard whispers of such festivities
before
doesn't the notion set your breasts to
flutter my breast
okay
let's go to d now
whip
drip
have we ever questioned how he gets
stuck there guys how does he get stuck
he gets stuck twice
by the way
oh
stop it
stop it okay
these guys are pretty sad too they're
just trying to get their head out of
that thing
and they can't
ooh two smithing stones we should go
upgrade our uh our katanas
we could definitely do that oh
my are you here as a customer of course
i'm here as a customer sir
give me all of your smithing stones and
sell sell sell
sell sell
i could just go to five and be much
easier i'm afraid i've very little to
offer
oh you're fine you're great man you're
great
a dog
oh my god two dogs oh my god
a doji
hi
what a cute dog
i really messed up in my last video guys
i called the turtle pope turtle pope
instead of dog pope
big problem there's no mistake is the
death has left its mark once again
who who is this
on the ground
ah
a tarnished arya
i'm known as d
i hunt down those who live in death and
weed their death root
heed my warning the village here has
been touched by death
and worse yet
dee does show up here to a mariner if
you value your life then go no further
i think that's all he says
thanks for all the subs guys we are
really close to 40k
which is kind of nuts
considering two weeks ago we were at 3k
that's kind of crazy no cappy on a
stacky
d's kind of hot are you guys attracted
to every character in this game
i'm getting these vibes from you
his voice is kind of nice though
oh i should probably use these rinse
um
strength to 20 and then vigor
thank you matt
yes
yes yes yes
okay
hey yo what up
oh man
sometimes she doesn't do that
godfrey versus malakath who would win
uh
godfrey
man
well
i like the boat boss
they're
absurdly easy
but i like the boss i think it's cool
also uh d shows up over here again as
well
don't even have to rest he's just here
another fool who won't listen to reason
eh
but with a prowess for weed in death
root
hmm
how would you like to earn the strength
of peace and then the church he wants us
to go to is very close to living death
and weed their death root
then i'll introduce you to garank
the beast clergyman i have a matter of
my own to attend wouldn't uh plastics be
the original lord of the great tree what
are you
yes very well
show me your map
i've marked the location for you
of a hidden gateway
it will lead you to garank the beast
clergyman
bodie mcboat face
i have a matter of my own to attend to
i spotted the mark of this centipede
here in the village
an ill omen symbol there should not be
someone or something threatens the
sanctity of the golden order
and must be eradicated
malakath was only was the only boss able
to beat melania really
i have seen those youtube videos from
i don't know who that is i don't know
who the youtuber is why is this not here
what the heck
oh
okay it turned on like a light bulb
interesting
um
where they he just like has certain
bosses fight against each other which is
pretty cool
i don't know who that is though
i forget
but we need to go down there
which
we can right here
oh god
platforming on torrent is not uh easy
not cc toll
what okay
could grab all these but nah
oh kenneth is here as well
forgot about kenneth
holy [ __ ] this is pretty one who might
be interested in rescuing the great
kenneth height
servant to the true order and celebrated
repudiator of the false
grant me a sucker ah you've come to lend
me your aid have you
well that's
it's very kind but um
no
no the help is i haven't looked into the
graveyards even from a tarnished
do you see the witch's video
dragonflies can technically be mounted
really
that's pretty cool i want you to take
back my fort
it lies to the south beyond the mist
wood the knight commander from
stormville took it a fool and plumber
chat i will kill kenneth if you tell me
to because he has the worst quest line
in the game in my opinion
press one in chat if you want me to kill
him two if you want him to live
he's a nerd
but i will do what you say
that's a lot of ones bro
that's a lot of ones
i don't care about the stone that's the
thing
[Music]
he gives you a seed
don't you need him to make nafeli ruler
of limgrave yeah we do
do we need godstock for that because we
killed him
um
i won't kill him
i know a lot of you guys said one the
kiss goodbye
my fault i think we will failed 100
take it back for me
oh i see i just don't like this guy
fred not
the great kenneth height is known for
his considerable largesse
the celebrations will be lavish indeed
upon the dawn yeah and we don't get a
celebration by the way we don't get one
just slap him
that let's get out of here
i'll go back to him
him him and celebus are my two least
favorite characters in the game
which ending are you going for we're
gonna try and have all options and then
chat can pick the ending
boom got our physique
our physique
that was will smith
yes
maybe
uh yep in
steadily restores hp restores half
i like the restore
oh i like mel in his dialogue here as
well
dung eaters the worst
but he he never tries to trick you he's
never a dick
he's just bad you know what i mean
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america
who vanished long ago
if you wish
i will share them with you have you guys
ever seen um gideon's dialogue on ronnie
it's really creepy
very well
in america's own words
my lord
and thy warriors
i divest each of thee of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed
ye will be driven from the lands between
he will wage war in a land afar
where ye will live
and die
well
perhaps that might serve you
in you of a maiden's guidance
is there a way to cheese radon i don't
think so anymore
there used to be oh i forgot to do the
sacred yep
gossip's hot you guys think everyone's
hot
everybody
all right let me go talk to kenneth
again
can you make him fall into the ocean i
believe they fixed that
i think
the horse too slow i actually don't
fight radon on the horse at all
you can dodge all of his attacks
underneath him
hey uh sorry i punched you in the face
earlier yes now allow me to furnish you
with a little advice
i would take great care to avoid
godric's tarnished hunts where i in your
shoes
is nafeli godfrey's daughter or gideons
sacrificing tarnished like nafeli is
godric's or godfrey's daughter
when he was a warrior horaloo in the
badlands
don't make me laugh gideon is her
adoptive
capital then hit from redundancy
gideon's adopted daughter then he
insulted melania lost to her in battle
only to lick her boots rather than die
like a man
i saw the pacifist run it was pretty
hilarious
and to think
he's the blood of godfrey you've died to
radon 78
[Music]
what are you waiting for
a kiss goodbye
my fort lies to the south beyond the
mistwood wait doesn't he talk about uh
godric what are you waiting for my foot
no i think he already did and i wasn't
listening okay
let's go
to
uh blide so we're gonna go
how what's the best way to do this
we'll probably see blide
we'll go to the castle
yeah yeah yeah we gotta go to
kali to even
talk the blind
what is this
yeah i wasn't listening to him that's my
bad
butt slam
yes sir
where am i going not the right direction
there you are
that's not it either
welcome
i still need to upgrade
okay
we're done at 50 oh my god
that's very good
yeah uh
if you're dying to a boss 78 times
you're probably under leveled for that
boss
just as a little tip
probably
[Music]
you're level 46 that seems under level
for radon
yeah 46 is pretty low
what do you think you're gonna beat this
game in two days man
this game took me two weeks to beat
took me 58 hours
oh god he is coming huh
uh we can update the boss list in a
second
kill the rat
oh my god
dude these delayed attacks man
the late attacks are the death of me
there we go
bloody slash that's pretty cool we can
get the grand lift of dex dectus up here
or one half of it
i'm two months in and still at the top
mountaintop the giants see there you go
and there you go
what level am i right now
35
and we've been playing for
two hours
you're at mount gelmere and you've been
playing since launch
well the difference is it's it's my job
to play this game and i'm assuming
that's definitely not the case for most
people you know
so of course i'm gonna
be quicker
[Music]
we should also get the map
what does this guy say
the demi humans wax
roth now their mother's been taken
whoops
their mother's been taken
where are you lord kenneth the knight
the devil by blood
well we just killed him he was easy
sword and fang
sword and fang
i'm lost already
i'm not lost anymore so that's all we
needed that's all we needed i want to
get the map though
what time is it because i need to let
the i need to walk the dogs soon
i can't afford xbox live
yikes
okay now we gotta go back over here
you know a live stream i did about a
month ago
uh was was titled uh dying to melania
for five hours straight wait
want you
well you're back
care to buy something
[Music]
he is best boy why not ludwig
thank you for the super chat man i
really appreciate that
signal right under the source
is his voice
like welsh really
i just have an inkling of you might hit
it off thank you very much man
i appreciate all the super chats today
thank you guys
goodbye for now goodbye
for now
thank you thank you thank you
it's eight foot tall
welsh wolf man
i don't know why because it's not really
the case
blide reminds me of my dog joy
and i do and i there's no reason for
that
i i just like him i guess i just like
dogs
half the cast is welsh
damn
i like it
you have a husky no i have a mutt
your hold on blind
this isn't going well so far
it's going well now
i thought i could kill him by doing that
oh no
there we go
but thank you again ludwig
you the main
you don't mean
that
is a very interesting comment md
ronnie's welsh too
hurtling atop a spectral steed
i've heard tails wait what is her voice
line there
i've heard tales
of a tarnished hurtling atop a spectral
steed
[Music]
heard tales of a tarnish
god i can't i can't dude it's so good
all right blind
[Music]
that's strength not snap
where's my snappy boy there we go and
boom
hey
who goes there
carly sent you diddy
never the bloody busy body
hmm
maybe to him you don't seem so strange
he's so cool
i'm looking for a man who goes by
darawell
he fled somewhere nearby
more also i've heard come tell me if you
find him before i do
i can offer you ample reward
do you guys want blide to start an asmr
youtube channel darawil is nothing but a
traitor
and in need of a fitting end to his tail
the the voice actor for him should
actually do that
pet blind okay wait
[ __ ]
that's not a pet um
uh
hey
there i'm petting him there we go
you're welcome
all right now we gotta go help him at
daryl which is right up here
we're kind of killing it today no cap on
a stacks will escuela
this might be the last thing we do today
because i have to go take care of the
dogs
they need to go they need to go poop
blind reminded me of that
the dog's got to go poop
ronnie's got the best voice in the game
i i there's so many of them that are
amazing
couldn't even tell you who's the best
just preference at that point
this is the evergale that eg puts blide
in
reichard's is the best
his is the most memorable because he
talks like a freak dude
daryl
rotting in a cell is known
oh yeah no
this is where it ends for you
so did darewell used to work for them
like for ronnie
if he's calling him a traitor
get him blind
kill
[Music]
good job my man good job
easy
moog is cool so we're basically listing
off every character in the game right
every every character in the game is has
an amazing voice actor
good job blood
hey good job hi i know you like pets
you wait tummy rub
you want your tummy rub
hey get it tummy rub
good job blind
okay
ah right
there you are did you like your tummy
rubs but it's done you want a treat
don't say i'm not a man of my word you
give me a treat
here's your prize thanks
it's actually a really good reward i
should say
if you venture north to rail lucaria and
come across a venerable blacksmith who's
a little on the line ronaldo was
originally going to summon blide and the
bloodhound was a replacement right i owe
you one i reckon ooh
interesting there's enough chit chat for
now this time we parted ways
all right chat
i think that's gonna do it for today
that's gonna do it
we will be back
soon i always want to say like i'll be
back tomorrow but i don't like streaming
multiple days in a row i kind of like it
to be special
sometimes but i do want to stream a
little bit more often than i have but i
do want to get to work on the next video
haven't haven't decided on the next
video yet but i do want to you know
think think something up in and write a
script and and see what we can do
i really appreciate all the support
today like ludwig and um and bones and
um
someone else earlier with all the super
chats i really appreciate it you guys
are freaking awesome
it means a lot it really does trey trey
had a five dollar one earlier
um and joseph earlier today as well so
you guys are amazing
i'll be back soon look out for the next
video
um
go watch you know make sure to subscribe
to the channel
i'd appreciate it guys oh and and follow
me on twitter i i want to tweet a little
bit more than i have but you know
just go to my twitter i'd appreciate it
other than that i hope you guys have a
great rest of your day thank you for
being here i've i've been having so much
fun streaming on youtube the last couple
months it's it's been awesome so
thank you
have a great rest of your day and i will
see you all
soon
peace out
have a good one bye bye bye